[Musique]
bonjour vladimir victoire veilleurs
bonjour monsieur car oui vous avez fait
acte de candidature aux élections
municipales à rivière pilote le 20
décembre dernier et il se trouve qu
ainsi six ans après votre père lucien
veilleurs qui était le maire en 2014 le
maire sortant vous vous retrouverez face
au maire sortant là en 2020 raymond
théodose donc les montées au dos qui a
battu votre père lucien veilleurs en
ils reviendront sur le contexte
particulier qui se posa à rivière pilote
pour ce scrutin mais ma première
question vladimir victor veilleurs c est
ce que c'est une candidature de revanche
personnelle c'est victor vladimir
veilleurs ag à verser
oui victoire vladimir vgr excusez moi
alors je souhaite à tous les
martiniquais qui nous écoutent une bonne
et heureuse année 2020 notamment aux
pilotis new piloter une candidature de
revanche personnelle par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé il ya six ans alors je
vais vous faire une petite confidence
lucien veillant avait décidé de ne pas
se présenter en 2014 aux élections pour
des raisons qu'il a expliqué il est où
est revenue sur sa décision
moi j'avais un premier attention est
fission le désir de me présenter j'ai
été les gens en 2014 nous non non j'ai
parlé de maintenant doit maintenant la
corde on attendait ce que vous expliquez
c'est que c'est un veilleur a été un peu
réquisitionnés bref il a changé d'avis
tout à fait mais est-ce que c'est par
rapport à sa défaite de 2014 que vous
avez décidez vous de vous présenter non
pas du tout non pas du tout c'était une
intuition et j'ai été appelé par les
pilotins qui me disait faut quoi les
focales et et par une équipe de kiki
avec qui je travaille une équipe
compétente de gens bourrés de talent et
qui m'ont demandé de des plaquettes de
liste d'unité pilotine alors le fils
d'un ancien maire qui souhaite être à
son tour mère est ce que ça peut pas
donner l'impression d'une forme de
dynasty d'héritage rivière-pilote c'est
une question il n'ya pas d'héritage en
politique et encore moins arriver à
pilote la population tranchera en mars
alors je parlais de contexte particulier
effectivement à rivière-pilote pour ces
élections municipales et communautaires
de 2020 puisque il ya plusieurs
candidats issus de la mouvance du mime
du mouvement indépendantiste
martiniquais alors dans un premier temps
d'ailleurs ces jus de biron un qui était
pressenti pour le pour être le candidat
de minneapolis pilotine on le rappelle
quand même parce que je n'ai pas dit au
début et donc je te vire ont finalement
s'est retiré et c'est vous qui avez été
donc désigné ou élu donc par ce groupe
l'unité politique de la limité du groupe
une unité pilotine m'a demandé de me
présenter et de mener cette tête de
liste à la victoire en mars 2020 voilà
voilà donc en lieu et place de julie
biron qui était d'abord pressenti mais
donc subir on n'est plus là mais en face
c'était voilà et puis donc vos
concurrents denis louis régis issus du
mime edouard marrant et raymond théodose
le maire sortant qui était aussi un
ancien ami de du mime et notamment de
son président alfred marie jeanne
donc comment vous appréciez ce contexte
particulier avec cette rivalité que
certains pourraient qualifier d' interne
ou même mouvement
non non pas du tout il n'y a pas de
rivalité interne d'ailleurs à part
edouard marc et moi même les autres ne
sont plus du mythe monsieur raymond
théodose accueille son parti monsieur
données du voyagiste et api a maintenant
donc non n'y a pas de rivalité je suis
le seul candidat du mime soutenu par
alfred marie-jeanne et je l'en remercie
mais je vais vous faire aussi une petite
confidence ce cette élection a aussi un
volet politique important et nul n'est
censé ignorer et aucun candidat n'est
censé ignorer qu alfred marie jeanne a
décidé de se représenter à la présidence
de la collectivité territoriale de
martinique
nous n'allons pas le lâcher nous
n'allons lâché aucun piloter nos papas
fanatisme par hamouda ou par idolâtrie
mais pour deux raisons premièrement pour
sa bataille pour la défense des intérêts
de la martinique
et deuxièmement parce que nous aurons
besoin de cet homme de se pilotait pour
nous aider à faire avancer nos projets
pour le développement de la ville de
rivière pilote donc au moment venu je
demanderai aux pilotes un de se
mobiliser massivement
pour alfred marie jeanne alors donc
victor vladimir veilleurs si vous êtes
élu en mars 2020 quel sera pour vous et
votre conseil municipal alors la
priorité des priorités
il y en a tellement vous savez le parmi
toutes ces priorités
l'allèle à vos yeux qui revêt l'urgence
la plus extrême
il ya des actions urgentes à mener le
plus il faudra absolument que la ville
se dote de plus c'est un outil de
politique de développement et politique
pour la vision du développement de la
commune sans local d'urbanisme le club
local d'urbanisme
deuxièmement l'assainissement le tout à
l'égout n'est toujours pas opérationnel
à rivière-pilote ce qui handicape
énormément vie au pilote et les pilotins
qui coûte cher à tout le monde à
l'espace sud et toutes les communes qui
en font partie
le ccs sylvia pilote doit se doter d'un
véritable ccas avec des personnes
compétentes le le développement
commandes irish la jeunesse nous avons
des actions concrètes pour la jeunesse
je vais pas les développer ici
vous comprendrez bien pourquoi même pour
nous donner un exemple par exemple de ce
que vous entendez proposer la jeunesse
nous y apporterons à la jeunesse de tout
âge la petite enfance les moins jeunes
et jusqu'à 25 26 ans qu'on appelle les
jeunes couramment des solutions adaptées
et personnalisées à leurs besoins les
associations qui sont un socle qui sous
lequel doit s'appuyer la ville de
rivière pilote nous aurons à la mairie
de rivière-pilote un bureau des
associations afin de les aider pour
l'eau gestion quotidienne aussi pour la
création d'événements arrivé au pilote
je voulais dire à ce petit mot pour les
employés municipaux administratif ou du
des services techniques qui ont qui
souffre d'un certain mal être et nous
les avons entendus lors de la campagne
et aussi ne seront pas les oubliés de
cette mandature
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
dans ce ca au caddie spécial municipal
victor vladimir veilleurs candidat donc
aux élections municipales et
communautaires à rivière pilote une
émission réalisée par patrice à la guise
à la chine
merci à vous